我想近這一個月來
我想很多人都關心這個
美國、以色列和伊朗的戰爭
一個牽動世界局勢的戰爭
今天我也想用這個作為一個開始
不過就從另外一個角度
我覺得戰爭是一個平台
你可以看到人在這方面的發明是很厲害的
在這次的戰爭裡面
你看到各樣不同的武器
不知道大家有沒有留意時事
在這個左上角
被稱為MOAB就是Mother of all bombs
就是常規武器裡面最厲害的一個炸彈
甚至投彈的時候
要用G170大力士運輸機的
因為太重太大
因為這個Mother of all bombs
是常規武器裡面最厲害的
如果你要提升那個戰力
你就要用這個非常規武器
比如說核彈等等
用到很盡了
旁邊那個就是鑽地彈
因為你知道伊朗有很多
那些地下的導彈城
地下的核設施
投射這些鑽地彈的就是這個B2轟炸機
左手邊下面那張就是
那個是一個魚雷
一個Mk 48超重的魚雷
我想你都還記得在印度洋
有一艘伊朗的護衛艦
在印度演習完
就回伊朗
在途中被美國的潛艇擊沉
其實這艘護衛艦不是大格
也不是很先進的
其實打它可以用飛彈都可以的
有時候用飛彈
你還會給它時間能夠逃生
但是它們竟然用到這個魚雷
你看見在YouTube裡面
你可以看見很快就沉了
當時蘭卡
當時蘭卡的舊船艦去到的時候
其實船已經沉了
為什麼會用到超重魚雷去對付它呢
聽說當日在美國的潛艇
那艘叫洛杉磯級的潛艇
有兩個澳洲的海軍人員接受訓練
你知道澳洲就買了美國的核潛艇
也都
某程度就默許了
如果太平洋第一島鏈有什麼事
澳洲就會出兵
所以其實當日在潛艇裡面
應該也是一個實戰訓練來的
而旁邊那個
都很厲害
那個叫石密彈
就是說它威脅
炸伊朗的發電廠的
那你發覺不是傷害民生的那些東西
因為他們發覺有一個現象就是
在一些鄉村、在一些人口少的地方
大概用電量很高
很可能就是背後有一些核設施
又或者有一些軍事設施
所以他們為什麼美國要求
要脅說要炸這個發電廠
但是如果炸了發電廠就不得了
影響很多人、影響民生
這個石密彈是什麼呢
就是它一投入的時候
那些石密本身令到有很多的短路發生
就令到它輸不了電
但是那個發電廠
和那些發電設施是沒有被摧毀的
那你可以看到是不是很厲害
其實這些的戰爭科技
又例如美國的無人機
Lucas無人機
另外無人快艇、無人艇
你看到左下角有一個叫做star shield
其實這個也是space X的
Starlink是為民用的
Star shield是為軍用的
所以你發覺如果拆開那些無人機的機頭
有一些接收器的
那就是那些star shield的導航來的
另外在這個右手邊的上角
那個就是激光炮
其實近年由2023年開始
他們很流行的一件事情
就是所謂的飽和攻擊